let's say we're trying to understand the
relationship between people's height and
their weight so what we do is we go to
10 different people and we measure each
of their heights and each of their
weights and so on this scatter plot here
each dot represents a person so for
example this dot over here represents a
person whose height was 60 inches or 5
feet tall so that's the point 60 comma
and whose weight which we have on the
y-axis
was
125 pounds and so when you look at this
scatter plot your eyes naturally see
some type of a trend it seems like
generally speaking as height increases
weight increases as well but i said
generally speaking you definitely have
circumstances where there are taller
people who might weigh less but an
interesting question is can we try to
fit a line to this data and this idea of
trying to fit a line as closely as
possible to as many of the points as
possible is known as linear
linear regression
now the most common technique is to try
to fit a line that minimizes the squared
distance to each of those points and
we're going to talk more about that in
future videos but for now we want to get
an intuitive feel for that so if you
were to just eyeball it and look at a
line like that you wouldn't think that
it would be a particularly good fit it
looks like most of the data sits above
the line
similarly
something like this also doesn't look
that great here most of our data points
are sitting below the line
but something like this actually looks
very good it looks like it's getting as
close as possible to as many of the
points as possible it seems like it's
describing this general trend
and so this is the actual regression
line
and the equation here we would write as
and we'd write y with a little hat over
it and that means that we're trying to
estimate a y for a given x it's not
always going to be the actual y for a
given x because as we see sometimes the
the points aren't sitting on the line
but we say y hat is equal to
and our y-intercept for this particular
regression line it is negative 140
plus the slope 14 over 3 times
x now as we can see for most of these
points given the x value of those points
the estimate that our regression line
gives is different than the actual value
and that difference between the actual
and the estimate from the regression
line is known as the residual
so let me write that down so for example
the residual at that point
residual
at that point is going to be equal to
for a given x the actual y value
minus the estimated y value from the
regression line for that same x or
another way to think about it is for
that x value when x is equal to 60 we're
talking about the residual just at that
point it's going to be the actual y
value minus our estimate of what the y
value is from this regression line for
that x value
so pause this video and see if you can
calculate this residual and you could
visually imagine it as being
this right over here
well to actually calculate the residual
you would take our actual value which is
125 for that x value remember we're
calculating the residual for a point so
it's the actual y there minus what would
be the estimated y there for that x
value well we could just go to this
equation and say what would y hat be
when x is equal to 60 what's going to be
equal to let's see we have negative 140
plus 14 over 3
times 60.
let's see
60 divided by 3 is 20 20 times 14 is
280 and so all of this is going to be
140.
and so our residual for this point is
going to be 125 minus 140 which is
negative 15. and residuals indeed can be
negative if your residual is negative it
means for that x value your data point
your actual y value is below the
estimate if we were to calculate the
residual here or if we were to calculate
the original here our actual for that x
value is above our estimate so we would
get positive residuals
and as you will see later in your
statistics career the way that we
calculate these regression lines is all
about minimizing the square of these
residuals